ja mehr als sechs monate krieg in der
ukraine und endlich gibt es hoffnung für
millionen ukrainer wir wollen uns mal
ein foto angucken aus einer stadt deren
name schwer auszusprechen das aber
vielleicht wären wir uns alle noch
merken wie so kopiert dieses foto aus
boskoop ihr haben gestern die
ukrainische armee veröffentlicht
beziehungsweise einen präsidenten
berater und wir sehen vielleicht mal es
erinnert so ein bisschen an iwo jima wir
erinnern uns das hissen der
amerikanischen flagge auf dieser lange
japanisch besetzten insel hier sehen wir
ukrainischer soldaten die eine flagge
hissen die ukrainische flagge nach fünf
monaten besatzung in der stadt wie sie
kopie ja und zwar auf dem krankenhaus
der stadt das als sechs stockwerke
insofern können wir uns auch sicher sein
dass wenn man hier eine flak ist dann
ist man sich sicher dass es keine russen
mehr in der gegend gibt das foto hat mit
verifiziert es stammt ganz aktuell aus
wikipedia wir sehen ja verschiedene
häuser dahinter und hier ein tank
dahinter an denen man auch ganz gut
sehen kann wo das genau aufgenommen
wurde wir sehen uns das ganze mal auf
der karte an und schauen uns das für den
süden der ukraine an hier haben wir seit
fünf bis sechs monaten in teilen sogar
die besetzung die russische besatzung
und wieso kopier ja hier ist hier ganz
im norden der region person und wir
haben das schon mehrmals beschrieben
dass die ukraine versucht seit monaten
diesem teil von rason also den
nördlichen teil abzutrennen vom
südlichen und das könnt ihr sogar
gelingen denn wir haben mit den
genervten diesen mächtigen den er bei
diesen fluss der eben die region in der
mitte teilt und die ukraine versuchen
immer wieder hier anzugreifen haben
jetzt physiker hier ganz im norden
erobert und versuchen natürlich von dort
aus weiter nach süden vorzudringen das
ziel am ende ist die stadt rastan eine
großstadt mit einer viertelmillion
einwohner die irgendwann so hoffen
zumindest die ukraine wieder unter
kontrolle gelangen soll und die ukraine
haben nicht nur die stadt erobert
sondern wir sehen ist hier wir hören
vielleicht auch wie man sich freut auch
verschiedene große fahrzeuge eroberten
füße komponiert dass hier ein bmw zwei
russischen truppen also ein relativ
modernes wo sich das armeefahrzeug mit
denen sie jetzt hier gerade wegfahren
nachdem sie die stellung dort überrannt
haben der russen und damit es damit wir
uns nicht zurückkommen
bombardieren die ukraine weiter die
brücken über die bre das ganz aktuelle
aufnahmen draht von gestern abend von
der antonov ski brücke einer der
wichtigsten mehrere hundert meter lang
über die internet die wird immer wieder
von den ukrainern bombardiert
ihre eigene infrastruktur hier zerstören
müssen in der ukraine damit eben die
russen keine weiteren panzer keine
weitere munition in den nördlichen teil
mehr der region verbringen können wir
wollen aber auch in den osten des landes
sehen und zwar in der region rar archiv
dort gehen die kämpfe auch weiter
zwischen ukrainischen und russischen
truppen hier ganz im osten und wir sehen
uns mal ein video an mit dem man
vielleicht ein bisschen auch erkennen
kann ja welche einfache technik die
ukraine relativ innovativ möchte man
sagen einsetzen um eben den russinnen in
mit ihrer militärischen übermacht oder
zumindest ihrer übermacht ein feuer
starke etwas entgegenzusetzen diese
kleine drohne die wir gerade gesehen
haben filmt also hier ein haus mit einem
russischen soldaten in einem völlig
zerstörten und entvölkerten dorf wir
sehen hier der ukraine guckt dass ich
das an und dieses haus wir haben sie
eben gerade gesehen wird kurz danach von
der artillerie der ukraine angegriffen
und wir sehen hier das immer wieder
bemerkenswert im gegensatz zur
russischen angriff nicht etwa 20 30
schüsse außenrum erfolgen sondern jeder
schuss trifft genau dieses haus warum
weil es sich um westliche präzisions
artillerie 155 millimeter handelt wie
sie nach dem zweiten schuss der also
nochmal genau das trifft ich habe gesagt
relativ einfache dinge die innovative
angewendet werden wir sehen dass hier
noch mal um merken uns das einfach mal
wie der ukrainische soldat jetzt hier
weg rennt mit seiner drohne und wir
haben die drohne gefunden und das ist
also eine auto zwei drohne wir haben
hier in der mitte noch mal den vergleich
hier wurde gerade zurückgeholt hier ist
diese crotone zu kaufen jeder von uns
kann sie kaufen die kostet aktuell 1425
euro und die ukraine sind eben
angewiesen auf genau solche einfachen ja
manche sagen hobby oder spielzeug drohen
alltagsgegenstände die sie im unbedingt
braucht um den russen hier etwas
entgegen zu wirken also nicht nur die
schweren artillerie sondern auch kleine
chinesische drohen die ihr von uns
kaufen kann sind für die ukraine wichtig
um diesen kampf für sich zu entscheiden
[Musik]